while some countries worry about a
second wave of the coronavirus many
parts of the globe
still have not seen the worst of the
first outbreak yet
dw correspondents filed these
coronavirus updates
the peak of the pandemic in south africa
is yet
to come the country had a strict
lockdown in the early stage of the
pandemic to prepare the health sector
but although the lockdown has been
relaxed there's still
a lot to do let me give you one example
if you're going for coronavirus test in
south africa at the moment
you will need up to two weeks until you
get your results this is why the
authorities in the western kpa have
decided
you're only allowed to take a
coronavirus test in public health
facilities
if you're above the age of 55 or have
another disease
and you have symptoms by the end of the
year
experts believe there could be up to one
million coronavirus cases here in south
africa and
the authorities here in the western cape
are considering adding another 800 bets
in the conference center behind me india
is overall coming out of the lockdown
but the coronavirus situation
is worsening for the past few days we
have been seeing a daily reported spike
of over 9000 cases
the public healthcare system is
overstretched already
the death tally is also increasing and
while the government says that they are
prepared enough there have been multiple
reports of people
not being able to get tested on time or
find a hospital bed on time
with the cases climbing every single day
it looks like the worst is not over yet
for india
i live around the corner from one of the
largest hospitals in london in the uk
the big green building at the end of
this road at the height of the crisis it
seemed like the sirens never stopped
as hundreds and hundreds of patients
were brought in ambulances
now it's much quieter and yet the uk has
the highest death rate of coronavirus in
europe
and many people mistrust the
government's handling of the crisis
so i'm not the only one who fears that
there might be another spike
and that the sirens may once more be the
dominating sound
in my neighborhood the nigerian
government has continued to emphasize
the use of face masks
and other protective measures but many
people have become unconcerned about
getting the virus
and more interested in getting their
lives and businesses
back in order so when you look on the
street history and every person going on
no mask no sanitizer no
not keeping the necessary distance
it's scary it's scary people are not
staying safe because
many people are still going out of the
law some people are not wearing their
face mark and some of them they don't
even care they don't even believe that
they're school now various
things new zealand's team of five
million
crushed covet 19 but the celebration was
short-lived as that
very same team now faces a long road to
economic recovery ahead
obviously we have a lot of immediate
issues to address
unemployment international travel
and also just basically getting
businesses
back small businesses i mean i'm very
hopeful that it won't take as long as
some might anticipate
and now that we are in level one and
things are back to normal
but yeah we're having the borders closed
and things like that it will make it a
bit more trickier
as we open our borders that will be a
real challenge
and often the tourism is what brings the
money to the smaller centres
our rural areas so i think that's going
to impact them
very strongly there are still around 8
000 new coronavirus infections in russia
every day and restrictions are still in
place in most regions across the country
but by lifting the lockdown in the
capital the authorities have given
people across the country the sense
that russia has essentially beaten the
virus
the pandemic has driven a fault line
through brazilian society coronavirus
infections are surging in the country
but president jared bolsonaro has
repeatedly downplayed the gravity of the
illness
he and his supporters want lockdowns
lifted so economic activity can resume
protesters are pushing back and
mobilizing against bolsonaro's handling
of the country's massive outbreak
the digging began before sunrise within
hours
these activists had transformed brazil's
copacabana beach
into a shallow graveyard a memorial to
the country's 41 thousand coved 19
victims
and a call to action
this pandemic allowed all of our social
injustices
and the incompetence of the public
authorities to emerge
so we are here to ask for a change in
attitude from the president of the
republic
and the federal government as a whole
throughout the crisis far right
president xia bolsonaro has repeatedly
flouted social distancing rules
at one point joining an anti-lockdown
rally the group behind this protest
say he has risked public health and left
the country mired in death
and division tension spilled out on the
rio sea
front with one man knocking down the
installation
my son died from this virus at 25 years
of age
and this guy is clowning around with no
sense of respect for those who are
protesting
there needs to be respect the beach is
public and protesters have rights too
nobody tolerates that anymore causing
terror
that's terror that's silliness okay
the makeshift graveyard was meant to
hammer home the human cost of this
pandemic
in doing so it exposed the deep rifts in
a country
polarized over its leadership
[Music]
it's to the central african country of
cameroon now and the story of how
political rivalry is
holding back the fight against the
coronavirus prevention efforts
are concentrated on the biggest city
dwala now after a disputed election the
government has
banned the work of the opposition leader
maurice camptow
but he and his party are determined to
press ahead dw's blaise eung met
some of the aid workers defying the ban
these volunteers in cameroon are getting
ready to distribute kovic 19 prevention
kits
the hangout face mask and alcohol-based
hand sanitizers
are the market in dwala the country's
largest city
camaro's opposition leader maurice
campton created the organization
to help cup the spread of the corona
virus
people are happy to get the equipment
but authorities say it otherwise
the government says this organization is
illegal
and the activities are not arisen this
means
the volunteers distributing these
facebooks can be arrested anytime
by camera security forces
since they started the program a month
ago at least a dozen people have been
arrested
across the country despite their risk
volunteers reach out to disadvantaged
communities almost every day
300 000 kids have been donated in over
15 communities so far
vitalis otya a cameroonian actor and a
senior member of the team
says they are not backing down we are
going to continue despite all the
arrests and we are continuing
they have arrested people in south
malima they arrested people in kyoc
i was arrested in boya behemoth i've
distributed in boya today
and i've come back i've come to dwala
and i'll continue only
and i'll go back to boya because the
need is enormous
and we need to do our best so there is
no way to stop it
cameron's interior minister who banned
the organization
was not available on our request for an
interview
the new corona virus is rapidly
spreading in the country
with more than 6500 cases
face mask will make composure in april
the opposition has continued to
distribute hygiene kits to people who
can't afford them
i am so happy i have spent much from my
little savings to buy hand sanitizer
and i don't even have enough money to
buy food but i had to struggle to get to
jail
i'm now joined by dr mary stephen who's
working as a technical officer
at the w.h.o regional office in congo
brazil good evening to you doctor
the who won today that the pandemic is
accelerating in africa
is the continent ready
yes so we are seeing the outbreak
evolving by the day on the continent
but this situation if you look at look
at the different countries
it varies from country to country uh the
the
pandemic is is driven by 10 countries
over 80 percent of these cases have been
reported
uh from 10 countries in the continent
so we still have some few countries that
are reporting less than 100 cases but we
haven't seen the peak yet
on the continent and the countries
continue to enhance
their preparedness and readiness
capacities to respond to potential
increasing number of cases so we are
seeing
countries establishing community
hospitals trying to
build capacity or enhance capacity at
the lower levels of the health system
because
given the peculiarity of the systems in
africa
most of the capacities you find them at
the national level
but because of this potential of
increasing number of cases
they are beginning to decentralize to
build capacity to be able to
detect to test to isolate treat
and also contact with uh the the
the people that might have been exposed
to
positive covet cases including the
implementation of preventive measures
among the members of the community so
the issue of hand washing respiratory
etiquette
maintaining the the one at least one
disturb distance uh
right one meter distance away from
others dr stephen i'm sorry to interrupt
you but i do want to ask you this we are
still talking about
africa being the least affected region
in the world what is the explanation
behind this
yes africa is the least affected
region in terms of cases in terms of
deaths
so at the beginning of the outbreak um
you will recall that africa is the
continent that had
the importation of cases last so we
started having uh
our covered uh 19 cases by mid-february
when cases were reported across all
continents of the world
so before then um there were already
countries were already
implementing entry screening and some of
them were doing quarantine
of our travelers so now um
quite a good number of countries managed
to detect
those imported casey cases early enough
some of them were picked at the point of
entry some were picked from
people that were in quarantine mandatory
quarantine and and they were able to
limit
uh the further spread of of these cases
okay
in the communities so in terms of the
debts
we also have a a younger population
and that a low prevalence of uh the core
mobilities
that contributes to uh one's chances of
dying so these are some of the
factors that affect both the cases and
the number of deaths
very interesting and thank you for that
inside that's dr mary stephen
from the who in congo brazil thank you
[Music]
ukraine is one of the few countries in
the world where surrogacy
is affordable and easy to arrange but
the global health emergency has
prevented dozens of parents from joining
their newborn children the long wait has
been painful for couples
but potentially disastrous for
children's development
now some families have finally managed
to be united
our correspondent nick conley met one
such family
one month and three days late but at
least they're together
pilar and geraldes have traveled more
than 10 000 kilometers by car through a
continent in lockdown
to finally meet their daughter
she still has to get used to us she
doesn't know who we are
their daughter spent her first month
with a carer in an apartment
her parents only able to see her on a
screen
it was so sad we were crying just seeing
her pictures and unable to do anything
for her
you just feel so helpless all you can do
is wait
as their daughter's birth came and went
and with no end to lockdown in sight
all pilar and geraldis could do was
scour the ukrainian press with the help
of a translation app
on the lookout for some sign of hope
neither the spanish government nor the
ukrainian embassy could or would help
when they read that ukraine's human
rights ombuds woman had promised to help
parents enter the country
pillar and geraldis jumped in their car
to drive the
600 kilometers from their home in madrid
to kiev
our first trip was a leap in the dark we
didn't know what we'd encounter at the
borders
on route they received the long hoped
for permission to enter ukraine
we cried when we received this i didn't
think a piece of paper could make you
this happy
but it wasn't enough we passed all the
checks and we're just 500 kilometers
from kiev
then they told us no we just couldn't
take it anymore they were missing just
one document
enough for them to be turned back at the
ukrainian border
returning home to madrid was the only
option without their baby
a week later they were back at the
ukrainian frontier after a 7000
kilometer round trip to madrid and back
this time with the right documents and
they were finally allowed
into the country other parents have been
less fortunate
separated from their children by even
greater distances and still unable to
enter ukraine
how many babies are still without their
parents no one can say with any
confidence
we've lost months of our daughter's life
that's super
it was actually a month and three days
to me
it felt like a year spanish must sound
strange to her
she doesn't want to sleep she just wants
to listen to us
now she's finally asleep
pilar and gerald's journey to becoming a
family like any other
is not yet over to register their
daughter's birth in spain they'll
probably still have to go to court
in spain as in many other european
countries surrogacy
is a legal gray zone neither legal nor
illegal
the coronavirus lockdown was just the
first of many obstacles on that path
so we asked our correspondent nick if
it's known how many babies are still in
limbo as a result of the lockdown
we're all scratching our heads here
trying to work that out but it seems
that even the government doesn't really
know
so we heard from the ukrainian
government's human rights ombuds woman
who'd helped families like belarus to
enter ukraine
with special permission she says about
100 families have been in touch with her
over recent weeks asking for help
getting into the country
while those travel restrictions still in
place but experts say that is just the
tip of the iceberg they
um they estimate that most agencies here
in ukraine have been advising their
families to stay quiet not
to reach out to the government they're
worried about too much government
intervention they had been called from
certain lawmakers here
to ban international surrogacy so there
was a real worry about
coming out as it were and making clear
quite how big a phenomenon this is
um i think the pictures that went round
the world of those babies
in a hotel ballroom they really aren't
representative that was essentially a pr
stunt by a very savvy
um clinic director who wanted to get
international attention to resolve this
problem
most babies including pilar and gerald's
baby's baby spent that
first month the last month or two in a
private apartment with a carer
so the picture the reality a bit more
banal than those pictures but this
seriously
is an industry that um sees families
from across the world coming to ukraine
this is not just a european phenomenon
you have families
from as far as argentina saudi arabia
china some of those chinese families
it's estimated have been um up to three
or four months late picking up their
babies given the lockdown started in
china earlier than in europe or north
america
so this really is a global phenomenon
happening here in ukraine